Eigentlich ist das ende des universums noch lange nicht absehbar. Als dehnt sich immer weiter
Aus bisher war vermutet worden dass es so langsam aber sicher stirbt den sternen geht der brennstoff auto und irgendwann wird es so kalt
Dass ich natürlich jetzt sagt aber ein forschungsteam der harvard university ein anderes ende voraus ein einziges
instabiles higgs boson wird das universum zerstören und diese zerstörung könnte schon begonnen haben jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Tja das universum dehnt sich immer weiter aus und was wir die forschung wirklich verblüffend ist diese ausdehnung wird immer schneller
Vermutet wird als grund die dunkle energie
13,8 milliarden jahre ist unser universum alten bereits. Im 10 milliarden jahren wird von der erde. Aus kaum noch eine galaxie
Zu sehen sein sie sind dann einfach zu weit weg schon heute sterben sterne und es werden immer mehr bis sie alle
Kleinen und noch schwach schimmernde weiße zwerge oder eben schwarze löcher sind es wird dunkel
So war bisher die vorstellung vom ende des universums doch wahrscheinlich passiert etwas anderes hat jetzt ein forschungsteam der
harvard university herausgefunden das ergebnis ihrer studie ein einziges instabiles higgs boson wird zu einer riesigen
kettenreaktion führen die das gesamte universum
zerstören wird eine riesige explosion das explosion ist das teilchen das allen teilchen erst die masse verleiht also ein ziemlich
entscheidendes
Elementarteilchen erst 2012 wurde es am lhc dem large hadron collider
Dem riesigen teilchenbeschleuniger in genf gefunden das hat selbst eine ziemlich große masse und zwar so groß wie zwei
Eisenatome ihrer studie nach ändert ein einziges explosionen in diesem prozess seine masse und wird damit der stabilisiert in der folge
Ergreift eine riesige explosion das weltall und es wird quasi
in einem zweiten urknall zerstört irgendwo in der gekrümmten raum zeit um ein schwarzes loch kann dieser prozess
seinen anfang nehmen in diesen extrem seltsamen regionen können teilchen in ihrer interaktion auch sehr extrem
Beeinflusst werden was die veränderung der masse eines exposés zur folge haben könnte
Und es könnte schon begonnen haben nur sei das higgs boson dann so weit entfernt dass wir es nicht
Feststellen können zitat es sieht aus als wenn wir genau an der kante zwischen einem stabilen und einem instabilen
universum werden wir sind eben an einen punkt an dem das universum sehr lange existieren kann aber
irgendwann ein großer knall kommt das sagte der physiker josef lüken von fermi national accelerator
Labors der sun er war dicht an der studie beteiligt aber auch die
forschungsgruppe gibt entwarnung auch wenn das higgs boson bereits instabil geworden sein könnte
rechnen sie mit dem daraus resultierenden knall in einer wirklich sehr
Sehr weit entfernten zeit wenn das universum bereits unendlich viel länger schon kalt und tod ist in achtung 10, hoch
139 jahren dafür gibt es ein wort das
Im 10 presse wie gehen die lionen eine zahl mit 139 0 eine milliarde hatten 99 es ist also
unvorstellbar lange noch hin und sie haben auch ein mindestalter des universums berechnend 10, hoch
58 jahre das sind leichter auszusprechen zehn
milliarden auch das ist unvorstellbar lange in die zukunft wenn ihr bis dahin hierbei klicks
Um nichts verpassen wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert und zu beginn
dieses
beitritts zur whatsapp community habe ich noch ein kleines geschenk für euch einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter dafür auch. Draufklicken gab es keinen urknall ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran